welcome to this video can't FM Conte
young don't have a good score against
this guy one out of three hmm not good
thus laughs but I have no real memory
what those games were like okay so we
get a queen's gambit type of position is
going for c6 night bd7 yeah the Queen on
v3 is not particularly well placed here
but could be worse it is it is quite ok
let's say it's interesting to see now
what kind of development plenty hairs
form for his um yeah exactly for his
Bishop so I know he's doing something in
that regard I'm going to take care oh
that didn't expect okay I thought you
would take with the sea pong
yeah this this might lead to a position
we have pretty nice pressure in the
center yeah I'm going to go back now I
it's got 95 I didn't really think about
it night c-5m
hmm
yeah that's not good yeah my best piece
only three a big drawback of course of
them what how came he can take it he can
do this next movie it's really something
that he should do but here before maybe
even deform ok let's go for that using
the activity here yeah I thought Bishop
c4 here as sir as always on let's see
maybe I'm completely completely
misjudging things
I can take with the rook now iam yeah
this is good for wide right I mean amber
porn up nothing nothing terrible
happening he's just plain if that like
nothing's happening and if 95 and all
kinds of things okay please kill them
Queenie for really d6 check check I
don't believe this is good I can take a
dried yet that that went downhill really
quickly eight hangs as well or is there
a big I know there is no lack there is a
no big idea behind it yeah this was
weird I mean this this is interesting
interesting position I thought you
should just play this immediately but
maybe I'm wrong I don't know this cannot
be bad for for black he's just netted
the just got the bishop pan I've got
more yeah I'm quicker in terms of
development in the sender word still
with the two bishops mm-hmm move like a
five or something should be okay
computer is giving black a slight edge
right here I mean I don't know somewhere
out here this is just giving giving up
on the game basically and it wasn't
clear we can do that oops check that is
not clear at all I mean the computer
gives like a pretty decent advantage
yeah this is basically just a check with
the special i7 but not more so bit bit
mysterious what here why he went there
when I went for Queenie seven down here
if you buy do here by this self
basically basically just winning those
those two pawns with support by the
bishop pam that's just winning compass
on plus 2.5 and climbing yeah they went
down it really quickly I'm not not
necessary at all okay well thanks for
watching